[Music]
what's your favorite part about these
every day is like super exciting just
like waking up and be like oh yeah after
just a few weeks of dating ariana grande
and SNL funny man Pete Davidson are
engaged
the couple has flaunted their PDA all
over social media and at Disneyland and
now it seems Pete's exes have something
to say about it girl code star Carly
Aquilino briefly dated Pete in 2015
shared this text message exchange on her
Instagram story Monday night on Tuesday
she wrote my love life going great
I quit cries into my burger Pete's most
recent ex Larry David's daughter Kathy
also seemingly reacted the same day the
engagement news broke she posted a photo
drinking wine in South Africa earlier
this month after Pete and Ariana's
romance became public Kathy wrote been
in Africa what'd I miss Pete and Cassie
dated on and off for two years Pete even
got a tattoo of Cassie space but now
fans have noticed the comedian had the
ink covered up check out this video Pete
posted last week look closely at his
right forearm it's drastically more
tatted than it was before
[Music]